good afternoon everybody
and welcome to this meeting of
mid-suffolk district council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk district council
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
please note the messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i will now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members we have council of field
and councillor welum in attendance today
and we also have the chief executive the
strategic director
and the monitoring officer in attendance
thank you
thank you very much so can i move to the
agenda please
item one is apologies for absence
we have no apologies today chair thank
you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members
are there any to declare
i believe that will be a no chair
thank you very much item three
mca 20 17
is the confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting of the mid-suffolk cabinet
count cabinet meeting held on the 7th of
december
2020 are there any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes
no okay could i have a proposal please
a councillor flatman chair happy to
propose the minutes for you
thank you councillor flatman and a
secondary please
um yes this is councillor jessica
fleming i'm happy to second the minutes
thank you very much councillor fleming
the governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern
gov app by clicking the plus sign on the
top right of the agenda
and selecting attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this item
will show in blue
that should appear now
thank you chair that's nine votes for
which is unanimous
lovely thank you very much
so item five sorry atom four to receive
notifications and petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
non-received chair and item five
questions by councillors
non-received uh thank you
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny
or the joint audit and standards
committees there were non-chair
thank you item seven is the forthcoming
decisions list
does anybody have any comments on that
no thank you
item eight is mca 20
18 and is the inter-authority agreement
between baber district council and
mid-suffolk district
council um
as councillors were aware we entered
into an inter-authority agreement
which was effectively a memorandum of
understanding between baba and
mid-suffolk district councils
when we first started working together
in 2012.
this agreement enabled us to ensure that
all staff are able to work for both
councils
and integrate services much has changed
over the last nine years and so it is
necessary to refresh the agreement to
ensure it remains
fit for purpose the revised agreement
has been developed between our three
statutory officers
the chief executive the monitoring
officer and the section 151 officer
i will therefore move the
recommendations in this report and ask
for a seconder
and then i will ask the chief executive
to summarize the changes made to this
new agreement and to answer any
questions
could i have a second to please
chair i'm very happy to second this uh
into authority agreement
in doing so i fully support the paper
and especially the fact that there will
be an annual review
of the content which will ensure it has
always kept up to date
thank you very much council brewster
do you have any questions from cabinet
members
jim and would you like me just to
quickly summarize a couple of changes
sorry sorry chief exec thank you very
much
yes no problem for councillor's benefit
i'm referring to
paragraph 4.3 in particular and
apologies should be given from the
monitoring officer who would normally be
presenting this report
but she's chairing our tactical
management team meeting at the moment
in relation to covert 19. so you can see
there in relation to
4.3 paragraph 4.3 this is largely a
technical and a governance report
it's simply bringing up to date uh the
agreement that was put in place
back in 2012 and so i'll just quickly
run you through those
bullet points and then take any
questions if there are any as you'll
know we've adopted the cabinet model of
governance
since 2012 and so there's a reflection
there of replacing the joint member
integration board
which is in place at the time and
replacing that with a cabinet
there's also been a series of
legislative legitimative changes since
then
so things like gdpr and the data
protection provisions and they've all
been updated within a report
the preamble itself for the agreement
has been updated
as you can imagine what was described as
the position in relation to the two
councils
back in 2011 2012 has completely changed
as we find ourselves now in 2021 and so
that's just been
updated to reflect the current time
the obvious one that would need to
happen is that the first agreement will
terminate
subject to agreeing to to enter into
this second agreement
and obviously both yourselves and baby
need to to agree to do so
as councilor brewster just referenced
there is now an annual review
to make sure that it remains up to date
so we're not going to just review it
every nine years but we will do so on an
annual basis
just to pick up any changes that may be
necessary
the document has also been strengthened
the agreement's been strengthened in a
couple of places
so the first of these is in relation to
the cost sharing arrangements
so under the old agreement those
cost-sharing arrangements
between the two councils was simply a
matter for officers to decide
it was a conversation between the
council section 151 officer
and one of the directors that's been
updated now to make sure that it also
includes the cabinet members for finance
and the leaders
and similarly the other change slight
strengthening i suppose
is that the replacement of the
integration of staff transitional
arrangements
clearly nine years on all of our staff
are working for both authorities
and so you'll see there it's been
included the actual details of the
section 113 agreement
which is the legal provision that
enables both officers or
an officer from one council to work for
the other and vice versa
the last three things there is insertion
of the arrangements so that you can hold
things like simultaneous cabinet
meetings that's just to reflect the
reality that you have done that on
occasions
at the removal of the transition costs
and premises clauses because clearly
we're nine years on and we now share a
building if we managed to ever get back
to it hopefully
but we now share a building rather than
having separate buildings
and then lastly just the insertion of
some clauses in relation to inquiries
hearings and proceedings and
investigations
so very much a technical in their
governance report but important that it
was brought up to date
for the benefit of both authorities so
i'll stop there chairman hand back to
you and if there's any questions
thank you does anybody have any
questions
anybody who's not a cabinet member have
any questions
oh councillor whitehead
thank you um i see the baby meeting on
the 7th of january so does
this come into effect immediately they
vote or what date because there isn't
anything written in the agreement it
just says
this starts on a blank date doesn't it
yes so once
once both authorities have agreed to it
so from the seventh uh
not wishing to preempt your decision or
baby's cabinet decision
uh but assuming you both make that
decision then we'll insert the relevant
dates uh
and get those signed so i suspect it
would be uh in effect from the end of
this
thank week thank you
i'm now going to open up the item for
debate and again if you can use the
hands up function
does anybody want to discuss this
counselor richardson
thank you chair um i'll just be very
brief i just wanted to sort of echo what
um council brewster's already said that
i think this is a
a welcome opportunity to to refresh the
agreement
um obviously a lot has happened in in
the last nine years we've adopted the
new cabinet model
and i think it is it's also quite
important we do have the annual review
mechanism
um within the agreement going forward
because obviously
as i said a lot a lot's changed over the
last nine years um but we've also
so many councils who are elected in 2015
or 2019 um this would be the first
opportunity they've had to um
to scrutinize that so i think that's a
that's a welcome inclusion um but as
as the chief executive was alluding to i
think it's quite sensible that
what we have now in the agreement is a
reflection of what we have been doing
already such as the
the formal now provision for for our
simultaneous cabinet meetings which
will hopefully mean we've got more line
decision making around areas where we've
got
um shared interests so i definitely
welcome this and as
the chief exec says it is a technical
and governance um piece of work but
obviously it is very important to the
work that we do
so i think this is absolutely right that
we brought this forward and we'll
continue to review it
every year thereafter thank you chair
lovely thank you councillor richardson
so i will now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members once again if
you go into the app
this vote should now appear in progress
in blue for you to cast your votes
just waiting for one oh there we go
that's nine votes for chair which is
unanimous
lovely thank you very much indeed item
nine
is mca 20 21
and is fees and charges for 2021-22
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for finance to introduce the
report
thank you madam chairman i'm pleased to
introduce the first of my three reports
this afternoon
which is report mca 2021 which covers
fees and charges for the year 2021-22
which starts on page 59 of our cabinet
papers
in previous years the fees and charges
schedule for the coming year has simply
been included
as just one apprentice of several
attached to our general fund budget
report
but we've taken the decision this year
to give it more prominence and its own
report
the council raises income approximately
four and a half million from fees and
charges
to put that into some sort of context
this sum is about 70 percent of the
total we precept
for our share the council tax and the
sum raised will cover 14
of our gross expenditure so we're
certainly not talking sundry income
the fees and charges schedule is set out
in appendix a
i'd encourage all members to review this
document in fact i go further encourage
all residents to review it because
i believe all be really surprised by
just how many services
our council can and does provide as well
as services for individual residents we
inspect and license a vast array
of businesses so that our residents can
use them all with confidence
my first thoughts when looking through
this long list with just how many fees
and charges
remain and change year on year the
changes we are proposing to our fees and
charges
are set out in paragraph 6.8 and 6.9
the changes are relatively modest with
bulk being at 3 percent
the recommendation i'd like to propose
is set out in paragraph 3.1
this is asking cabinet to approve the
fees and charges set out in appendix a
of the report
these fees and charges have been
incorporated into the general fund
budget for 2122
which we'll be reviewing later in this
meeting and having proposed
recommendation madam chairman
could you please ask for a second uh
thank you
thank you councillor whitehead to have a
secondary
um yes i'm councillor hading i'm happy
to um
second this report and i'd like to thank
the finance cabinet member for his
introduction
feast and charges an important source of
income to the council
enabling important services to be
sustained and provided
in order to sustain the delivery of
services in the future this revenues
is essential so i'm happy to second
second the recommendations are set out
in the report
thank you thank you councillor
so any cabinet members have any
questions can use the hands up function
please
any non-cabinet members have any
questions
yes i'll now open up the item for debate
again if you can use the
counselor field you have a question
i do yeah sorry i was a bit slow
reacting
that's all right just a couple of points
really the
the uh i note that um well at
tensorfield
um these are questions for clarification
only
yes the discussion yeah it was really an
issue of
the um the increases of three percent
i i noticed that a number of those are
in areas where
um suppliers you know shops and whatever
zoos i see on the list are are quite
challenged at the moment
and was just going to ask you know um
do you feel this is reasonable to
increase charges in the in the current
circumstances
happy to answer that i do think um the
charges
or the increases are very modest i mean
i take your point but
i don't think um some of these increases
which two two
three pound here and there would be this
sort of cam you know the thing that
broke the
camel's back so to speak but i i i
take your point as being a valid point
but uh i think
um three percent still is you know
modest increases
okay so you could have one more question
on uh you know
i'll resist the temptation to debate it
um
the i want a question starts with who
when where what why or how
thank you i wonder if i can do that uh
page 62
um legal implications it talks about
a recovery on a um well the sentence i'm
looking at a paragraph
uh clause i'm looking at says the latter
on a
cost recovery basis so that's
discretionary services
and i did wonder whether some of the
things we're
talking about there that cost recovery
basis
criteria is being met i wonder if i can
be
assured of that i either we're not
making a profit on some of the services
which we're allowed to do that
uh where we're not allowed to make such
a profit
i mean i guess until you get to the end
of the year and sort of look at what the
income is and what the costs are
you can never sort of put a hand on
heart and say that but if
either catherine or melissa want to just
come in at this point and give any other
assurances i'm happy to
hear from them
thank you councillor whitehead yeah i
can probably just add to that and say as
part of the budget setting process i
know that the finance team do talk to
the individual
corporate managers to look at what their
their costs are and and the income
so there's sort of an annual review of
that but as councillor white had said
it's when you get to the end of the year
and you've got your actuals that you can
see whether you whether you did recover
all your costs or not
thank you so i'm now going to open up
the item for a debate
again if you could use the hands up
function
if you wish to say anything
no okay so i'll now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members once again the
vote
is now in progress on your mod gov app
thank you chair that's nine votes for
that's unanimous
lovely thank you very much indeed
item 10 is mca
20 22 and is the transfer of the
vehicles
of the council's vehicle fleet to
hydro-treated
vegetable oil this item
is for voting only sorry for noting
only i will now ask the cabinet member
for the environment to introduce
the report
yes thank you guys as councillor jessica
fleming
and i'm very pleased to be introducing
this um this report and this proposed
action because
there are enormous benefits to the
environment
and to both baber and suffolk residents
by switching
to hydro-treated vegetable oil as i
think the cabinet report
says we have looked at alternatives
to to reducing emissions from
the waste fleet and the waste fleet
being
the largest emitter along with leisure
centers so
these two sources are where we've
concentrated our
efforts first to so-called grab the
low-hanging
fruits if we can
switch to the hydro-treated vegetable
oil we stand to save
at least 900 tons of carbon a year
between the districts
and this is something we need to do
along with baber it has to be a combined
effort
because the um fleets are shared it
would be impractical to do it
separately as as a district council um
also there are some important
pollution prevention savings in terms of
the
tail pipe emissions from burning how to
treat vegetable oil
as compared to diesel there are
consistent
significant reductions in all other
pollutants in particular
some fairly nasty pollutants called um
aromatic hydrocarbons which are
persistent
and toxic and are associated with the
combustion of diesel
the hydro-treated vegetable oil also
burns much cleaner
it emits less carbon pollution less
particulates
and will result in cleaner air for all
the areas
that the vehicles collect in
it runs well under all circumstances
better under cold conditions and is
generally
better for engines because of the
cleaner nature of the fuel
people may have some questions about you
know where is all the
um sort of used fat coming from that
will make up this material because we
are concentrating on
sourcing from waste vegetable oil as
opposed to
vegetable oil that's that's grown from a
biofuel crop
and i think that's very important to
note because
i think there are some life cycle issues
with biofuel crops
um some concerns about that but this is
based on
treating used vegetable oil and
at the moment the source we're looking
at comes from finland that's not to say
that it will be um coming from overseas
indefinitely because we're looking at
the british market
as well at the moment the cost is
slightly higher than diesel
we expect the cost to um to be
adjustable
both of the costs will adjust over time
so i think this is something
that is very important for us to do if
for instance if we want to
take this opportunity the costs to the
councils of meeting
our carbon reduction obligations would
no doubt be a lot higher because
this is one of the two low-frying
low-hanging fruit and as i say
i do hope everyone can support it i just
also wanted today to share a little bit
of news
about um a train journey that took place
on the 22nd of december
and um this was a
a test run by a class 66 locomotive
starting from british steel's plant in
scunthorpe and ending in southampton
this locomotive was fueled
took the first run with a hundred
percent pure
renewable hydro-treated vegetable oil um
the experiment was extremely successful
it was
um organized by dp cargo uk
and network rail and i think that
this just shows how um how well this and
how flexible this oil is
in um in a wide variety of engines
um so i was really pleased to hear this
um i think it's the start of something
really important and i do hope you can
all support the paper
thank you thank you very much
do we have a second
yes yes uh sorry just that was the delay
counselor burn
uh i'm more than pleased to um second
this
uh uh this proposal or this
uh this move to to move to
um hvo it's
uh obviously a
a a great um step to make in our
carbon reduction uh
aspirations uh and a very a very
significant one too
um uh the only thing that surprises me
is that there are
there has not been according to the
report
um an independent assessment of the
the co2 output for this particular fuel
which surprises me but um if we are
reassured that um we're going to make a
uh at least a 90 saving on co2
that's whole life co2 as it were from
uh planting the crop that supplies the
the oils um even though
it burns to produce co2 uh
a renewable source rather than a fossil
source
is obviously the way to go and i'm very
pleased we've taken
this initiative and taken it so soon as
well
it it ought to be a um an example
to other local authorities to do the
same i hope we can
uh i hope we can benefit from
from that um the fact that it
produces uh a good deal less
in the way of noxious elements and
noxious
uh substances that come out of the
exhaust as well
nitrogen dioxide sulfur dioxide
etc that is a
obviously a bonus
um beyond our carbon saving um
not least a bonus for the the operatives
who collect the bins and
and put them into the into the vehicles
uh it must be a much healthier
environment from
for them to operate in so it's a plus
point all round as far as i'm concerned
very happy to second it thank you very
much councillor bern
um this item is only for noting so
um do we have any any questions of
clarification on this
council of field
yes it is something to be supported as
you say but a note around
paragraph 411 there's some comments
about uh
the issues of palm oil and it says oil
of choice for hvo
is typically palm oil and clearly
there's a
volume issue there's quite a lot of
diesel used in the world and replacing
it all with hvo sounds difficult
so i wonder if councillor fleming might
sort of
expand on that area a bit and
just explain why we shouldn't be
concerned about the palm oil
implications um
we have we are specifying non-palm oil
content
fuel um i don't think i personally would
not be supportive
of any program that promotes
palm oil and i i think probably um
most of us feel that way um
i am actually myself amazed that we
that so much you know chips and
mcdonald's and etc
genuinely does produce so much
potential feedstock for this new fuel
however at the moment the supply seems
to be steady
my guess is that if it was scaled up to
be an actual replacement for red diesel
that um there would be some supply
problems
but we aren't we're not at that stage at
the moment at all and it's being widely
taken up
by um those who are forward thinking
and i i'm you know anxious for us to
grab the opportunity
i i do just want to mention um i did go
on
our um emission factor database a few
days ago
and as far as i could tell there is an
emission factor specific
to hydro-treated vegetable oil it may
not be
fully you know released now but it is
definitely
being developed and
it's you know it does have a different
set of emissions to all of the other
types of biodiesel etc slightly
different they
all have slightly different emission
factors so i i think if the emission
factor isn't already
published for use it will be very
shortly this is in in relation to
councillor burns question
um so yeah i i think at the moment we
haven't
met a supply barrier um
that remains to be seen john a good
question thank you
thank you thank you for that as i said
we are i think we're in support but
just there are some concerns in that
area i
thought thoroughly um i think i'm
completely in agreement with you on that
thank you and also the prerequisite that
no palm oil is used
will be built into our procurement spec
as well
anybody else have any questions
okay so we we don't need to vote on this
this is it for
noting only um thank you councillor
fleming for updating the cabinet on this
really really important
uh milestone that that we're about to
we're leading the way on so thank you
very much for bringing this to
cabinet very pleased to thank you
thank you councillor fleming item 11 is
mca 20 19
and is the draft general fund budget for
2021 to 22 and also the four-year
outlook and i'm now going to invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this report
thank you madam chairman my second
report this afternoon is a draft general
fund budget
2122 and four year outlook which starts
at page 123 of our pack
uh when i set up to present the budget
for 2021 back in endeavor house
in february 2020 a little imagine that
our whole world would soon be changing
so
drastically by the pandemic the section
151 officer the finance team together
myself and opposite number at bay by
council award have collectively spent a
great deal of time during 2020
establishing the effects of the pandemic
on the council's finances
our initial projections were horrendous
but as i advise cabinet when reporting
our quarter to out turn
forecast central government has been
extremely generous with their assistance
to local councils
helping us minimize the impact of the
pandemic on our finances
and some of that generosity will extend
through to the end of the first quarter
of 21 22.
there are lots of details in this budget
report setting out the financial impact
of kovid 19
and the present economic environment in
which the country found
itself now you can see paragraphs 4.5
through to 418
for lots of details there now like
ourselves the government has remained
focused on responding to the public
health
and economic emergency as well as them
being engaged in the protracted brexit
negotiations
and contingency planning and they've
therefore had limited time to raise
their sights to the future
and accordingly they've just announced a
one-year spending review
and put in place only a short-term fix
in respect of new homes bonus they will
soon be starting a consultation
on a future replacement for new homes
bonus but they have delayed the fair
funding review
the business rates review and a business
rates reset
and all this makes it very difficult to
make any meaningful forecast
beyond march 2022 for our four year
outlook
in addition the provisional financial
settlement was only announced on the
17th of december
that's the last possible date before the
christmas parliamentary recess
and just five working days before our
christmas break
and the deadline for the preparation of
this report
uh details of this provisional
settlement are included in paragraphs 4
19 to 421 but some of the changes have
still to be fed through into our budget
numbers
so cabinet should therefore take great
heed of the first word of this reports
heading
the word draft there remains further
work to be done before bringing a
finalized report back to cabinet in
february
for endorsement to full council the
cross party overview and scrutiny
committee
will likewise have their opportunity as
usual to examine our plans in detail
and make their valued observations the
budget we approved
in february 20 for the present year 2021
incorporated
increase in the midst of share of
council tax by 1.66
in that year and this increase was
assumed to continue
year on year throughout the four-year
outlook
this draft budget continues with that
assumption
these are modest annual increases which
along with a small growth
every year as new built homes become
occupied
mean that we'll be gradually building up
an ever more robust council tax base
to service for the future current
projection show is raising 6.382 million
from castle tax in 2021 22
increasing to 6.987 million by 2024-25
this draft budget does produce healthy
surpluses throughout the four-year
period
this year we are again adding one
million to the commercial development
risk management reserve whilst we are
still awaiting planning commission
on the revised master plan for our major
gateway 14 development
before groundworks can even begin we've
also added a further half a million to
our climate change and bio
diversity reserve provide a serious
amount of firepower
to these vital causes i believe we also
need to seriously consider further
additions to reserves to cover future
planning legal
and planning enforcement expenditure
which we need
to decide between now and going to full
council
we anticipate getting cifco fully
invested by the end of march 2021
and therefore no further capital
investment for yield
has been incorporated into our future
capital programme
the details of our future capital
programme from april 21 to march 25
are set out in appendix a so madam
chairman
fellow cabinet members and indeed all
members present i welcome your comments
observations and questions on this draft
fund budget report despite my caveats
that there will be changes to be made to
this draft before it returns here in
february
our expenditure is pretty much now
finalized and likewise best estimations
of our anticipated income streams
for the coming year i'm happy to propose
the two recommendations set out in
paragraph three
for cabinet's considerations and with us
for a second though
thank you very much thank you
councillor whitehead do we have a
secondary please uh
yes sir please uh madam chairman it's
councillor gould here
uh i'd very much like to uh second the
report
as council whitehead says in setting the
currency of budget
we had no notion of what was to come
the approach which built on the
administration's strong record of
financial planning and management
strengthened our resilience against
possible risk while making
making new provision for key policies
such as carbon reduction
the specific risk we planned for though
did not include
a global pandemic our initial
assessment of the impact on the
council's finances
suggested a hit of around 4.5 million
and here considerable thanks are owed to
the finance team
who worked unrelentingly hard throughout
the year
both to assess and understand the
financial impact of the pandemic
and to ensure we were able to recover
our full entitlement
uh from the government and it has to be
said that the government
has been more generous than might have
been expected
in compensating local authorities so
what appeared as an early stage to be a
substantial hit on our finances
has been far less serious and remain in
strong
financial health and our financial
position
does though uh contrast strongly with
that of of
many councils and so when many other
councils are working
to avoid section 114 notices we are in a
position
where we can contemplate extending the
provision we've made
for areas such as climate change and
biodiversity
into other key priorities such as
housing
economy and well-being this draft budget
not only lays a solid foundation for
financial planning
and management but it is an investment
budget not a survival budget
and it gives us the ability to support
and improve the communities within our
district
and so i'm delighted uh to second the
report
and its recommendations thank you madam
thank you very much councillor gold
do we have any questions
councillor fleming
thank you thank you um chairman and
thank you
um council of whitehead i i just have a
question
really on um surrounding business rates
i um i see in uh our reports
on um i think it's on page
let's see one two nine
that um we're expecting to get almost
two and a half million
in from business rates
if if i'm reading that correctly
um how confident are we in this given
the
slightly tenuous state of a lot of our
businesses in the district
who wants to come into that one well
i'll i'll make a start
but uh when it comes to business rights
i
defer to catherine's wonderful and
extensive knowledge on the subject
and so i'll be happy to her to answer
that on my behalf
thank you thank you chair uh the figures
you're actually referring to
on page 129
are the current years figures for
business rates but at the moment we are
projecting a very similar figure
at the moment that's one of the elements
of next year's budgets we do need to
finalize
it is an ongoing issue in terms of
business rates and business rates
collection
as we know nationally a number of
businesses have
folded some within our district have
have folded
as well the figure that we include in
our budget
is the proportion of the total rates
that we collect
that we're deemed to need from the
business rates
so we actually collect i think it's
somewhere in the region of over 15
million pounds in total for mid-suffolk
businesses
but what we include in our own budget is
the the government as government's
assessed
uh proportion that we can keep to run
our services
um i say it is a challenge
with business rates collection at the
moment but what we do
hold within the council one of your
reserves is called a business rates
equalization reserve and we use
that to try and smooth any peaks and
troughs in terms of business rates
so if we find we have any issues in in
say 2122 then we'll be able to call on
that reserve
to fund the losses and then that will
hopefully see us through the the hard
year and then hopefully things will pick
up in the economy again
in future years so i think the assurance
is that you have
that reserve to to be able to fund
anything that we have
okay thank you that's that's good to
know because um
that is obviously an element of
uncertainty going forward
thank you thank you very much
is there any more questions from cabinet
members
no cancer field
we'll continue with that point on
business rates for a moment could one
ask
um what sort of portion of our business
rates income is from
say the hospitality business businesses
of the type that we might expect to see
severely hit and what portion from
manufacturing industry or whatever you'd
like to call industries that
we don't expect to be hit
catherine are you able to answer that i
was going to say would you like me
um i'll try and do just a little bit off
the top of my head because i haven't got
the breakdown of the business rates
based
in front of me but i know the retail
hospitality leisure sector this year
they received 100
business rates relief this year and i
believe for mid-suffolk that was
somewhere in the region of four to five
million pounds in total
now if your total business rates base
is round about the 15 16 million pounds
then
we're looking at roughly a quarter of
the base
from that particular sector i'm afraid i
don't know particularly what the
manufacturing sector is but i know some
of
the bigger rate payers certainly in
mid-suffolk are from from the
manufacturing sector um so from that
type but i haven't got that particular
breakdown but hopefully that just gives
you a rough idea of the proportion of
the the retail sector that's been
getting the relief this year
thank you would that include people like
um i believe companies like tesco have
decided uh
not to accept that rate relief or
certainly some of the relief so
it would would that your maths then have
included them
it would have done because i think it's
a very recent announcement
that they've decided not to take that
relief
i think i heard about it literally just
before christmas
i think there was an announcement that
some of the bigger retailers
um perhaps you know tesco's and one or
two of the others have decided not to
take that relief
but yes they would have been in those
numbers that i quoted
okay so so of your 25
there's a fair percentage that perhaps
would not be too challenged
thank you for that uh could i ask one
more thing you i notice
i was just looking at actually a full
416 you talk about
cpi inflation falling and you talk about
point
eight percent in 2020 but i noticed a
number of the
elements of the budget include
figures like two point three percent
inflation there is so so
um i was just wondering whether you feel
you're adequately
uh taking account the fact that
inflation is likely to be
low due to the damaged economy next year
councillor whitehead um
yeah i mean i i certainly you know when
i was reading through notice that one or
two of these
inflations on projects etc were quite
in excess of the cpi but i did question
that
but um if catherine wants to sort of
address any particular
um major items there i certainly believe
we are well covered although i do have
some fears for
inflation in the longer term just
because of the way government borrowing
has just gone
sky skyrocketed sure
thank you so just
say thank you chair just in terms of
some of our contracts some of those have
got
different factors built into them so
it's not necessarily linked to
to to cpi so what we've tried to allow
for in the budget or where we know there
are different indicators
that drive the contract costs in future
years
so say there are a range of different
different factors
but yeah bearing in mind that overall
inflation rates are currently quite low
at the moment
thank you very much
so i'm now going to open up the item for
debate again if you can use the hands up
function
if you would like to join in
cancer richardson
thank you very much chair um there's
just a couple of points i want to make
really
i think the first is just to reiterate
what counselor gold said in in seconding
the recommendation in the report that
actually i think we should reflect on
how
fortunate we are to be in this position
to have had an extremely difficult year
and yet still to be in a position where
we can continue um to invest
in our local communities i think that's
that's quite an enviable position to be
in
um and i think in many respects that
reflects the fact
that um sound and careful management of
our finances is something that
mid-suffolk
has been a hallmark of mid-suffolk
district uh council and its
administrations for for several years
but obviously that in itself while
that's you know to be welcomed
um i think that's not an end in and of
itself we don't just
look after the the money for its own
sake i think what that enables us to do
is go
go further and do more to support our
communities which i think is is why
council court is absolutely right
that linking this in um linking our
budgets in with
our wider vision is absolutely right in
places like housing
the economy in well-being i think when
we looked
to set our vision back in 2019 i think
we were absolutely right then
to place that emphasis on healthy
communities and i think what's happened
over the last 12
months has in many respects just
reiterated the need to do exactly that
because obviously i know that our local
businesses our residents have faced
a challenge of an unprecedented scale
over the last 12 months
and will continue to do so and but i
quite passionately believe that
um the well-being of our residents and
our businesses and our wellbeing
strategy
a proactive well-being strategy will
absolutely underpin
the economic recovery that we will see
over the next few months so i think
that's absolutely vital so i welcome the
inclusion
of those aspects um in the budget so i'm
absolutely
happy to to support this even though it
is obviously any initial draft form
i think this is absolutely setting the
right tone so i shall definitely be
supporting it
thank you chair thank you councillor
richardson
so i will now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors the boat is
now ready for you
in your mod gov app
thank you chair that's nine votes for
that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed item 12
is mca 20 20
and is the draft housing revenue account
budget for 2021 to 22
and also the four-year outlook and i'm
now going to invite the cabinet member
for finance to introduce this report
thank you banjo i'm just sort of
rearranging my desktop so that
i've got my speech in front of me as
opposed to all the other ones
um yes the third report this afternoon
uh
i'd like to introduce is cabinet report
mca 2020
the draft housing revenue account budget
and four-year outlook
which starts on page 149 of our pack
as with the general fund budget this hra
budget is labeled draft at this stage
and we'll be coming back to february's
cabinet meeting for further
consideration before being presented for
approval
at full council later this month and i'm
also looking forward to taking that
along with general fund
to overview scrutiny later in january
for the year 2021-22 we are forecasting
a surplus on the hra
of 116 000 pounds this contrasts with
the large deficit forecast for 2021
of 564 000 but members will recall that
primate that was primarily due
to a slippage in our capital program
that we can now forecast
an out turn surplus for 2021.
i hope you follow that the table in
paragraph 5.2
compares the budgets for the two years
with explanations behind the various
line movements
and that's set out in detail in
paragraph 5.5
savings and efficiencies have been
identified during a robust budget
setting process
i won't go through those now as they are
there for members to peruse at their
leisure within the report
but i would like to talk a little bit
about our castle house rents
in april 20 we increased our council
house rents by 2.7 percent
being the consumer price index at the
time plus an additional 1
this was our first increase after four
years of a centrally government-imposed
reduction of rents
by one percent each year for the coming
year from first of april 2021
an increase based on september 20 cpi
plus one percent
works out to be only 1.5
the net effect of these decreases then
increases over the six year period
is that for our average council house
weekly rent
in march 2022 will be only 11 pence
higher
than it was in march 8 march 2016
in other words virtually unchanged
we will not be changing our sheltered
housing utility charges in 2122
there is an element of subsidy presently
built into these charges
but we have seen some reduction in the
price of gas electricity
and especially oil we can therefore
freeze these utility prices for 2122
while still making some reduction in the
level of subsidy
members will recall that we did not
increase sheltered housing service
charges in this current year
there remains an element of subsidy
within these charges
and to eliminate this subsidy in 2122
we would need to increase service
charges by two pound ninety
we are not proposing to make such an
increase and the recommendation
is an increase of just one pound per
week
now i would hope that we can find
cross-party support
for such a modest increase particularly
as it follows on from two years of zero
increase
members should also note as mentioned
within paragraph 5.5
that we intend to develop a rent and
service charge policy
for our sheltered housing during 2021
with a view to bringing it into effect
for the following year
turning to capital members will see we
have an ambitious
ambitious capital program for the four
years from 2021 to 2025.
working within sini the council has
identified
development sites for 254 affordable
homes
and 119 shared ownership homes
new bills and acquisitions are forecast
to cost 42.2 million
and our housing maintenance program 15.8
million
appendix a on page 159
shows how we intend to finance this
capital program
and finally i'd like to draw members
attention to what i think is one of the
most important paragraphs in the report
that's paragraphs 4.2 this explains how
we will be reviewing
our 30-year hra business plan to
incorporate new build specifications
the design guide and environmental
retrofit improvements
and new safety enhancements and this new
business plan which will be articulating
our vision for council housing
should be coming to cabinet this summer
i'd like to move the recommendations set
out in paragraph three
and would ask councillor having him as
the cabinetman for housing
to kindly second them thank you very
much
councillor adding him thank you madam
chairman
as the portfolio holder for housing i
would like to thank my fellow portfolio
holder for finance for his introduction
to the hra budget for the year
2021-2022 the income the hra receives is
invaluable in supporting our tenants to
ensure their homes are safe
decent and places tenants are proud to
call home
the work of our team supports tenants to
manage and maintain their tenancies
while supporting them to succeed and
thrive
it is evident from the report that the
services has continued to build on
is continuing to build on a solid
foundation whilst maintaining services
throughout the chronovirus pandemic this
year within the housing
um service development has included new
software to improve services
the development of data sources to make
manage and increase
performance while developing services
such as the neighborhood and estates
team
or and the expansion of our tenant
engagement service
i second this report and the
recommendations set out as as within
paragraph three
thank you thank you councillor
any questions anybody
cancel the field
thank you i don't expect you to be quite
that quick
um the um i'll search for my question
really the the the um obviously there's
uh
we should discuss this largely at um
uh scrutiny so i won't take a lot of
your time but uh
i noticed uh the statements about the
cpi past percent increase um
and that's impact on council house rents
and while it's a low figure
clearly these are vulnerable people
the real issue i was going to ask is the
last
time we were extending increasing rents
in this way
telling ourselves that they largely came
out of
housing benefits that weren't a problem
uh the government retaliated by forcing
us to reduce rents by
one percent a year for four years really
question is um
how are you assessing the probability
that you'll get that reaction again
cancer whitehead
sorry i just i followed you all the way
through to the very end but i'm not
quite sure what
what what the reaction you were
referring to
a government reaction which forces you
to reduce rents yet again
um i mean so clearly the impact on
tenancy is is small but
in the wrong direction but nevertheless
small
but but the last time the government
reacted to
us and presumably a vast number of other
councils increasing their
housing benefit bill by telling us to
put it back down again
and that was the one the issue that i
wondered what your assessment was
i think i'm going to bring in gavin fisk
on this one what can i just sort of say
i was trying to cover that i think with
my
introductory speech insofar as we're
saying over the six years
an average rent that will be 84 pound 58
next year was actually 84 pound 47 if
you do all the math working the
percentages
ups and downs back to six years ago i
suspect there's no
there's a one six year period in the
history of council housing when the
rents only went up by
that amount over a six year period but
um i'd be happy and so
i was surely the government would take
that into rest into account when
look at looking forward but i'm happy
for gavin to had his thoughts to that
kevin
you've just gone on to mute in
thank you chair and thank you councillor
field and council whitehead
i i mean no one can um clearly second
guess uh
future government policy um that would
be
uh would be slightly crass um the the
reality is that we've obviously faced
um as a landlord and as social landlords
have
um a reduction in rents um that has
obviously been of benefit to
tenants um but that has meant that we've
probably have been able to be less
ambitious in terms of uh our approach to
new build um and to the improvements to
existing homes
uh what we do have and the only
certainty and security we can look to is
current rent policy
and that rent policy uh permits an
increase as set out in the report
i think for housing providers per se
they need a level of security around
rental income
in order to deliver the huge number of
new social homes that are required
to meet needs in addition to
future spend on environmental
improvements so
no one can can second guess what the
government might do
but they will at least give us direction
for a rent policy
um at least sort of five years in
advance of any decisions
thank you very much councillor willem
thank you chair um yes um
well i need to respond to councillor
whitehead's prompt regarding
sheltered housing charges is it not the
case that the service charges are
increasing because the number of units
are is reducing because some of the
overhead costs are the same no matter
what the number of units there are
and so as the number of units reduces so
the cost per unit increases
councilwoman the the whole service
charge
area is one that i know that our
officers are looking at
for example in baber i think they've got
13 sheltered units
and and there are 12 different sheltered
charges charging regimes in that
within that figure whereas our 14 units
all have the same uh charge a week which
i think
memory is 30 pound 83. um but
um and i know um there is a lot of work
can be done over the next
six months uh we had quite a
conversation with vinnie and i with
uh lee crowdell on this and we're
looking forward to
him bringing that forward and
from my perspective i would think
some cross-party involvement in that
would be welcome just because it just
seemed to be a
political potato at the moment and i
think that
my own personal views it shouldn't be
that way
thank you gavin thank you chair i think
just to
add to council whitehead um um
we're not seeing a reduction in the
number of units i think the process of
um de-designating or de-establishing
uh sheltered housing schemes were
decisions that were made
some time ago historically and i think a
lot of that work is is now complete i
think
um the work that council whitehead
touches on which is
it planned for 21 22 um
is looking at the uh service charge
budget
and looking at the pooling or depauling
um that
perhaps needs to take place to ensure
that the surface charges are fair and
equitable to all
um clearly where we have uh had
additional expenditures this year or
over the last couple of years
is around obviously building safety um
improvements and i don't think anyone
would question those but
uh particularly on on the the back of
the grenfell tragedy
we've certainly invested far more in um
fire security fire prevention and fire
uh investigation in terms of the yearly
checks that we carry out and
and that will inevitably uh mean that
we're conducting more work
um as such as removing asbestos and all
of those other
uh component parts that we've been
looking at but um yes
the work that we'll do this year will uh
bring forward
um a proposal on the charging uh in the
future
thank you very much cancer field
i was just going to make the point that
i'm sure um
green and lib dem group would welcome
any cross-party involvement in
setting policies i tend to agree that
this
shouldn't be an area where political
considerations are
in any way dominant so i'll be happy to
see that happen
and there's some illustrations i think i
say we'll look at most of this budget
during scrutiny but
there are i noticed for instance that if
one compares the spend on
environmental improvements to our
housing stock in general
there's uh it's it's quite a low figure
compared with some
other expenditures like one that gavin
just mentioned on
fire safety etc so there certainly are
areas there which i think
discussion could be uh valuable to
hopefully to all concerned
yes thank you councillor field we
welcome
your um your work working with us on
this
um no more
debate so i'm now going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you thank you chair once again
members the vote is now in progress in
your modgult app
thank you chair that's nine votes for so
that's unanimous
lovely thank you very much indeed
moving on to item 13 this is
mca 20 23
and is the proposed john peel center
expansion
the report is in two parts part
one is the public part to the report and
part two is confidential
which covers the appendices a c and d
so i'll now invite the cabinet member
for economic growth to introduce this
report
thank you councillor brewster
cancer brewster
i'm sorry sorry
thank you madam chair i am delighted to
introduce this item
which we meant which recommends to
cabinet the proposal to grant a new
40-year lease
on the former nat west bank building at
11 marketplace stone market
um to the john peel center
the council commissioned a report
earlier this year in partnership with
the john peel center
which reviewed opportunities for the
sustainable growth of this key
structural anchor
in the town and its positive impact
on the wider town center and generation
as as part of the stone market vision
the position of 11 marketplace building
offers a front door to the jpc
enabling the organization to expand
their operation
and provide a significant heritage
heritage and cultural tourism boost for
the town
as well as the wide ascend area of
mid-southwark
as well as improving the confidence and
marketability of the jp
c through a more visible high street
entrance
proposed works within the building will
also enable the jpc to offer
a broader spectrum of events and
activities
through both reorganized and increased
floor space options
also a green room capacity
the successful growth and cultural
development of the john peel center
will enable the ambition for stone
market to flourish as a center of
excellence
for creative cultural technology
technological and innovative support
opportunities enabling a high quality of
life
a vibrant town centre and a benefit for
all in the community of the town
and the wider district this outcome
is underpinned by a cross-cutting
program of project delivery
and intervention that builds on existing
advantages
and develops national and regional
attractions
such as the national museum of food and
the john peel center
and one might add the regals of that as
well
this is an example of how we're
investing in the future regeneration of
our towns
by giving people a new and exciting
place to visit
we can increase visitor numbers to the
town which will provide an economic
boost as well
it is one of a number of exciting
developments
set to help the town's post covered
recovery
which includes the new look regal
theater benefiting from 3.6 million of
investment for a comprehensive expansion
and reverb
refurbishment program
as cabinet member for economy i am
committed to investing in the growth of
this cultural asset for the town
therefore i am asking cabinet to approve
the following recommendations
which will support the objectives of the
stone market vision
properly monitor the council's
investment in the john pill center
and ensure funding is secured for works
to improve that building
these recommendations are and note the
note the key recommendations of the
consultant report
approve the grant of a lease on the 11
marketplace to the john peel center
which will be conditional on the
jpc providing a formal business plan
acceptable to mid-suffolk council the
provision of an acceptable funding
strategy
for the refurbishment of the building in
two phases
making the necessary governance
improvements proposed by the report
delegate authority to the assistant
director economic development
and regeneration in consulting in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for economy
and i would like to add to the
recommendation and the portfolio holder
for
assets and investment to finalize the
terms and legal agreements for a long
term lease for the building
which is suggested for a 40-year period
at a token rent
and approve the draft process proposed
kpis
which will be inserted into the lease
and which for members information can be
found
on page 398 of the paper
madam chair i i propose this
recommendation to be accepted
and uh look for a seconder
thank you councillor councillor
thank you chair i'm absolutely delighted
to second the recommendation
and look forward to to the
to the john peel center occupying the
whole of the building
and utilize the front entrance as their
shop window
the opportunities for a cultural center
at the heart of the town
are endless bringing yet more tourism
and spend into stone market and the
wider district
thank you chair thank you council
flatman and do you accept councillor
brewster's proposal to include the
portfolio holder for assets and
investments yes absolutely
thank you very much thank you does
anybody have any questions
no does anybody wish to debate
councillor gault
thank you very much ma'am chairman um as
um council brewster said uh the
uh is this fight by the john phil center
will help
support the growth of the cultural arts
venue bringing more visitors to the town
center and giving
the center more prominence in the town i
just wanted to make the
the simple but important point that the
value of the john peel center within
stone market
exceeds any commercial rent that could
be achieved for the for
the building and that's the way i think
we need to assess it
this is a great uh great development
fully supported
thank you thank you councillor gould
council whitehead
thank you madam chairman uh just to echo
really
uh councillor ghoul's comments i mean we
bought this uh uh
um several years ago for quite a modest
amount of money
and the fact is we're not giving it away
although we're giving it on a peppercorn
rent we are retaining the freehold so
that
asset is there we'll be there in 40
years 50 years 60 years time but
i think it really underlies to me just
how exciting
uh things are getting in stowe market
now
where i live and residents around me the
gravitational pull of ipswich is
is very strong whether it's leisure or
entertainment but
the fact that we we now can see stone
market sort of blooming whether it's the
regal
or the john peel center and this
wonderful vision that miser has for
stone market
is great and so i'm very very strongly
in favor of this
development here thank you thank you
councillor whitehead
i think if there's no more questions and
there's no more debate hands up
i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair members the
vote is now in progress in your modgult
app
thank you that's nine votes for chair
that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed so item
16 on the agenda is confidential
so we're now going to go to the
resolution to exclude the public which
term includes the press
to consider whether pursuant to part one
of schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during this item
it is likely that there would be
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against this item
the author of the report to propose to
be considered in
part two of the agenda is satisfied
that the public interest in maintaining
exemption outweighs the public interest
in disclosing
the information do i have a proposal
thank you madam chair i'm very pleased
to be able to
propose this this uh exclusion of the
public
thank you councillor brewster uh
councillor flatman
are you suffering yes chair i'm happy to
second the proposal to
go to um closed
thank you very much councillor flatman
um i'll now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that's nine votes for
lovely thank you very much
so the confidential item 16 is mca
20 24 and is the disabled facilities
grants
sorry chair can i just confirm with rob
that the
live stream is stopped
you